[موسيقى]
وعند انقطاع الكهرباء
وتذكير الطريق الى اسرائيل والخارج اعتمد
الناس بشكل كبير على اوراق الطينه
الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
انا محمد ابو صالح من مدينه بني سهيلاف
خانيونس
اعمل في افران الطينه وبدات فيها من
سنه ال 2000 والحين صار لي 22 سنه في
عاملها وباعملها باتقان
وقفران الطين وتستعمل اشياء كثيره منها
الخبز البلدي وخبز الطابون
واشكال متعدده كثيره منها الكبسات ومنها
الصواني ومنها المندي ومنها الكعك
[موسيقى]
والله تعلمت الفئران الطينه
في القديم القديم اللي هو عندي اربع سنين
خمسه من سته
ما متعلقتش فيها فعندما كبرت سنه
انقطعت ما في اعمار خالص في الشغل ولا
عمله فاعت الذكريات فتذكرت انه الست كانت
تعملهم انا كنت انا اقولها فبديت قعدت شهر
اتعلم فيها رجعت ثاني
هلقيت عمري صار 22 سنه صار لي الحين
بعملهم الاولاد
[موسيقى]
ومن مواد الخام الذي استعملها الطين اللي
هو الحصمه والحديد والاسمنت
انواع ومنها الصفراء ومنها الحمراء
الذي يبيعها العرق الاصفر او الابيض لانها
اقوى في العمل وتصمد عندك فوق الست سنين
سبعه اما الطير الثانيه
سنتين وبيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
احس بالسير الطلب عليها كثير هذه الافران
في فصل الشتاء لانه
في الصيف الناس تعتمد على
الفرامات تطلبها
[موسيقى]
ولكن هناك صعوبات كثيره ومتعدله بالنسبه
لفرن الطينه لا توجد
اسمنت حصنه حديد باسعار باهضه عشان هيك
الناس خفت الطلب عليها لانه بسالوني
احيانا بكم اقول له 80 شيكل 100 شيكل
وعليه السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
ولكن الناس تقدر تدفع وبتجيب في ناس
بتقدريش
دافعين كهرباء بنشتغل على الكهرباء
وتذكير الطريق الى اسرائيل والخارج اعتمد
الناس بشكل كبير
لانه لا يوجد شمس حتى يجب
[موسيقى]
عشان تراثي فلسطيني